today tarapoto is feeling good but the
past two years of his life have been
dominated by a legal battle that left
him feeling way out of his depth so
present the coming gardening is like
therapy it's calming and it does me good
to be outdoors the trial really took its
toll on me remember I suffered from
depression Daquan second-screen osceola
we're simple people who aren't used to
being involved in big politics but the
pressure almost lettuce to divorce the
commenda no to cooper honest mmm fiji
boxy tee Elly Pato has gone up against a
powerful force in French politics the
right-wing phone nacional yet he had
high hopes when he joined the party back
in 2011 the portos were most impressed
by marine lepen the leader of the fall
nacional and the daughter of the party's
founder jean-marie Le Pen they felt that
marine was taking the party in a new
direction away from the right wing
course pursued by her father she made a
name for herself by demonizing the party
like he's weaker it might sound
laughable to some but marine lepen
reminded me a bit of Nelson Mandela in
her speeches she said she wanted to
unite French citizens regardless of
their background I think that our
society is very divided and that bothers
me yes commissioner of you
tfd and his wife Nadia joined the party
and not only that they also offered to
be candidates for the fall Nacional in
their village of Santa bomb near
Toulouse supporters of the party's new
direction they quickly distanced
themselves from the politics of
jean-marie Le Pen who had been
repeatedly found guilty of Holocaust
denial jean-marie Le Pen became infamous
for claiming that the gas chambers in
Nazi concentration camps were a detail
of history but after a year and a half
in the fall nacional de patas realized
that marine lepen views weren't so
different from her father's was just
like hot dog I've been answering this
question for 30 years and I've always
been very clear on this subject for me
the gas chambers aren't a detail of
history they're a symbol political
scientist no no my heir says marine
lepen won't break completely with her
father's views for fear of putting off
right wing supporters said in certain
manasa feel if a machine was always
genres favorite the daughter who never
betrayed him he systematically helped
her get where she is today against the
wishes of the old guard many of them
were against her because they felt she
was too left-wing and didn't embody the
right-wing nationalism they defend
unless you're not a different the portos
also soon felt the ire of the right-wing
nationalists during the local election
campaign two years ago one day one of
the local heads of the party told me
when the phone less you now come to
power we'll set up a guillotine on
Capitol Square then we'll give teen all
the Arabs the gays our political
opponents the Socialists and the UMP
that shocked me because they do it was
even worse for me and my children to be
told that we were ready for the ovens
because my family comes from Algeria
that was too much for the portos
they left the four Nacional and went
public they refuse to let the party
silence them and even fought for their
rights in court yet constant threats and
harassment from fanatical party members
forced them to leave their home the
phone arsenal has many other disgruntled
members they're disappointed with the
party's direction under marine lepen
they've seen her hang on to the party's
anti-european anti-islamic and
anti-semitic views just couching them in
different terms the insights and
experiences of these members could prove
dangerous for the party her father is
stopping her from coming to power so she
has to do something either he tows her
line or she'll finish him off he's got
no choice but he always wants to be in
charge sort of fleece on the conformist
they're one in the same to me the
fullness you now is and remains a
right-wing party Emmeline the pen knew
that when she joined years ago she won't
change now the fuss on the buses naveen
has now suspended her father from the
party he founded and the portos are
enjoying watching the lap ends public
TIFF I have the feeling he just can't
stand the National Front continuing to
exist when he's no longer its leader
that's it I'm sorry should all get
security to those who want me dead and
buried I say the corpse is still alive
and well yeah political experts view the
lepen family feud and the father's
temporary expulsion from the party as a
calculated move
law psychological support they're
fighting because too important electoral
events are looming regional elections in
the fall and presidential elections in
2017 in Marylebone marine lepen doesn't
want her father to harm the softer d
demonized image she's created for the
party vidya so she's trying to
emancipate herself from her father and
that's where the problems start he feels
that his creations escaping his clutches
TFE Pato has won his legal battle with
the phone arsenal and can speak openly
about his experiences he gets a certain
satisfaction from watching the lapels
harm the party with their infighting but
he has no plans to get involved in
politics again any time soon